we have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P. Up.
This is a voicemail that relates to media
literacy.
Unfortunately, I'm worried.
I'm worried.
This is one of those voicemails that attacks
me for things that I don't actually claim
to be.
Take
a listen.
Hey, did the.
Really, that.
With, honestly, you and your coverage of.
You know, just on the news.
Oh, no.
Especially in the light.
I mean, I've never really been.
A huge fan of your message that you have this
sort of mainstream media manufacturing consent
sort of technique to you, pretend like you're
not biased or that biases are wrong or that
you're somehow like objective and just calling
balls and strikes when you're clearly injecting
your opinion.
OK.
So this goes on for three minutes.
But guys, come.
How many time we we need media literacy.
You know, we hear Fox News viewers can't distinguish
between news and opinion programing, and FOX
uses it to their advantage.
I have always been on equivocally unapologetically
clear.
This is an opinion show.
This is a left wing show.
I do my best to be objective with the facts
and then I give you my opinion, which is a
left wing opinion.
So criticize me for something real.
But criticizing me for pretending that this
is not a left wing opinion program.
Come on, guys, come on.
We're in trouble if this is what we're dealing
with.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
And we have a live debate stream tonight.
Joe Biden versus Donald Trump.
Join me at eight thirty p.m. Eastern Time.
I'll see you the